في زمن الدوله العثمانيه كانوا خوال
الرئيس مطاردين من قبل
الجندرما اللي هم الجيش العثماني
لجوا الى اكثر من منطقه ما حموهم فنصحوهم
باللجوء الى قبيله الدليم اللي هي قبيلتي
قبيله الدليم ممتده من حدود صلاح الدين
الى يعني منطقه بعيده الى حد سوريا الاردن
المملكه العربيه السعوديه فاول ما لجا
الاول عشيره نصحوهم بان يلجاوا الى عمق
الدليم يعني عمق القبيله حتى يحموهم اكثر
اذا اجوا والجندرمه وحصل قتال ممكن
يتجندروه ما راح يسلموا يعني ما راح
ياخذوهم يقبض عليهم
هذا الرجل اللي اول عشيره قال لهم تروحون
عند العشيره اللي راسها فلان شيخ وهذا
الشيخ لا يمكن ان ينطي دخيله فلجاوا
لا يسلم من يلجا لا يسلم من يلجا لا يسلم
الدخيل
كل العشائر العراقيه الدخيل لا يسلم لكن
هذا الشيخ حتى لو اقتضى القتال قتال
جندرمه او العثمانيين سيقاتلهم نعم بعد ما
لجاوا لهذا البيت
وصلوا هذا الشيخ برا الهم وقال لهم لا
يمكن ان نسلم دخيلنا وعلى سبيل الاستطراد
احنا راح نسال يعني ابسط انسانه عندنا
اللي هي مظلومه مظلومه هاي متزوجها واحد
من عشيرتي من خوالي وهي امراه مشهدانيه
ومشهوره بالشجاعه والمشاهد وكل المشهورين
بالشجاعه والكرم
فقال لهم ابسط مرعى عندنا بالعشيره راح
نشرها فشاروها قالت لهم اني اقص داياياي
اذا تسلموهم فطلعوا يرمون قال شرناها وعيت
مظلومه رفضت رفضت رفضت رفضت يعني العين
للرفض نعم
فجمعت العشيره وانهزموا الجدرمه انهزموا
وبعدها اضطر يعني العشائر الاخرى ان
تتدخل
يعني نصحوا الجندرما بان يصدر فرمان
بالعفو عن البيجات اللي هم خوال الرئيس
وفعلا صدر فرمان من السلطان العثماني
بالعفو عن تذكر رئيس لماذا استذكر
اني من العشيره الفلانيه فقال لي هاي هاي
ما اثركم يعني انتم الكم بالتاريخ يعني
ماثر مو غلب عمق التاريخ